So, we'll need to identify our region.
Again, I'm using these regions of
circles, which is scale invariant.
A property that this region would
have to have is that it should not be
affected by the size and will be
the same for all corresponding regions.
To build on this, let's actually kind
of think about a simple example.
This simple example basically says that
average intensities are interesting
things to observe.
For any corresponding regions,
even if the object is of different size,
the average intensity, the image
pixel intensity in that region,
will be the same.
So while we zoom in and out, we need to
start looking at the fact that if I do
have a region in both of those parts,
the average intensity of that region,
if it's the same object,
should be the same.
Because as I said, it's the same object,
just viewed at different scales.
We resolve this,
by again computing the intensities
at different scales at a point.
Compute the scale invariant
function at different sizes and for
different neighborhoods.
And then choose a scale for each image
at which the function is maximum.
Let's see what that can be.
So again, this is the function
that I'm looking at.
This is my intensity.
And I'm going to scale
up the region size and
see where I actually
find a certain peak.
Of course this could be done for
Image 1 this way.
And of course now I have an image
that's half the size of the object and
an image that's half the size.
Again, if I was to take the region size
and measure the function that changes,
it'll actually have the same peak, but
it'll actually be doing it much faster
just because the image is at half scale.
So just basically now start seeing is
that the peak and stuff like that for
this function are the same, just how
it impacts with the region size.
So we need to start thinking about
where we can find functions like this.
Of course, this kind of starts telling
us that we can find, again the scale
here is important and the scale for this
one would be, these are the two scales.
If I know that, I should be able to
now compute where in which region,
which size of the circle do I
want to use to look at an image for
detection of features.